is
how do we discern the voice of the holy
spirit
before i answer that let me pray again
father in heaven as i continue to speak
on your behalf
put your words literally in my mouth as
david said in 2nd samuel 23 2
the spirit of the lord spake by me and
his word was
in my tongue do that for me their god
not for my sake but for your glory
and for the enlightenment of your people
whom you love so much
in jesus name i pray amen how can we
discern the voice of the spirit the
voice of the spirit
is genesis to revelation now i say that
as a foundation on which to stand when
trying to determine
the word of god is supreme above
everything
in psalm 138 verse 2 the bible says thou
hast magnified thy word above
all thy name any conviction any
urge any decision we try to make
any message that comes to us must be
judged in the light of god's word
there are people with mental problems
who tell us they hear
voices telling them go and kill this
person go and kill that person
now is that the voice of the spirit of
course not thou shalt not kill
and so the voice of the spirit can be
verified
by comparing what the voice has said
with thus
said the lord and so the voice of the
spirit must be consistent
with the very words that the spirit has
inspired because the spirit cannot
deny himself any more than jesus can or
the father can
this puts upon us the burden to know the
word of god
because without the knowledge of the
word of god we are at a deficit
we are handicapped in our ability to
identify the voice of the spirit
that is why so many people are misled
because they and their minds are not
coated with the word of god to correctly
identify the voices that come to them
i was in a certain country a few years
ago and i spoke to someone
and i said you go to church the person
said yes i said you read the bible the
person said no
i said why not the person said my pastor
reads it for me
that person will have difficulty
identifying the voice of the spirit
because the voice of god is through the
word of god yes sometimes
in my life i have heard the voice of god
tell me do this and that
but as i study the word of god i
realized this was consistent with god's
will
and so we identified the spirit's voice
by comparing it with thus saith the lord
there
is no higher standard than thus
saith the lord and we try to get around
it but i must also repeat
thus set the lord becomes operational in
our lives
as we study and obey
john 7 17 if any man will
do his will he shall know the doctrine
when we have a desire to obey
and we study god's word and live
according to that which is revealed
we developed the ability without being
able to explain it
to identify this is the voice of god in
other words
we jesus said in john 10 my sheep know
my voice
you need to come to the place where you
know even if no one else knows
this is god speaking to me and the only
way to do that
is through constant study and praying
but
as a technical response or a straight
response
we identify the spirit of god by
thus saith the lord the spirit will
never convict a person
to take an action that contradicts god's
holy word
amen amen to that and so we definitely
have to as you mentioned
read the word of god consistently on a
day-to-day basis
you see a lot of us are lazy and i don't
mean to condemn anyone listening a lot
of us are largely lazy
just tell me let me use my time to do
something else
no no it is a tremendous privilege to go
to the bible
and have the spirit of god reveal truth
to you
there is nothing more precious than that
and so take the time study the word
as you do that you will learn to
identify the voice of god
that's guaranteed amen amen
amen after that the writings of ellen
white
amen and and you will definitely hear
that small voice
whenever you're making a decision um and
it's always going to try to guide you
the holy spirit is going to guide you
into the truth never into error
so we have to be very careful what we
are here uh so the second question elder
skeet is
um oh this is a backup question upon it
how do we identify the holy spirit
in someone else all right
the bible says by the fruits ye shall
know them
matthew 7 14-18 we shall know them by
their fruits
now we know from galatians 5 22 23 but
the fruit of the spirit is love
joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness
faith meekness tempers those are the
fruits but there's uh
the fruits must be combined with the
gifts
there are two different things the
fruits will be eternal the gifts will
come to an end
in the new world they don't need we
don't need the gift of healing we don't
need to give the prophecy the gifts are
temporary
the fruits are eternal but they work
together one of the gifts according to
first corinthians 12
8 to 10 is discerning of spirits
because we know from 2nd corinthians 11
satan is transformed into an angel of
light
therefore it is not no great thing if
his ministers also are transformed into
the ministers of righteousness
error can be so close to truth you
cannot tell the difference unless you
have
a refined understanding of god's word
and so we need
the spirit of discernment to realize
no no no no this is not true light it is
light
but it is not true light and so along
with the study of the word of god
we develop the spirit of discernment
because deception
keep in mind the devil deceived perfect
unfallen angels he deceives them and
according to ellen white it was only up
until the cross
when some angels saw what satan did to
christ that they finally
broke off all sympathy with him what i'm
saying is this
perfect angels for thousands of years
still felt
that satan had been badly treated so
deception
is a very powerful thing we combat it
with the word of god and obedience
as we do that we develop the spirit of
discernment
to decide this is not of god i may not
have scientific evidence
but i discern now parents will
understand what i'm saying
here comes a young lady she brings a
young man to the family
and the father chats with the young man
for a while and
discerns without any proof this young
man is no good
he's a demon in suit he is no good or
the young man brings a young lady to the
family the mother meets with the young
lady
and the mother comes away and she has
discerned
this young lady is as lazy as whatever
and so discernment is not based on
scientific evidence
it is something we develop in our study
of god's word
and continual obedience to him and so we
identify
someone is led by the spirit by thus
saith the lord and also
by that internal power of discerning and
the power of discernment is the spirit
himself speaking to you
when ananias and sapphira came to uh
peter
just to give him the money for having
saw some land in acts temple five
they both lied peter knew they lied
because the spirit gave him that power
of discernment
we need it and it is one of the things
lacking in the church
we have no discernment inside that style
of dress is wrong
that kind of music is wrong that kind of
behavior is wrong we don't have that
discernment
because we don't study the word of god
but discernment is a gift the church
needs
and it works along so we have the fruits
and we have the gifts and one of the
gifts is discernment
and that will identify if someone is of
god or not
but there are certain obvious things you
can see but the things that are not
obvious
the spirit of discernment will make them
clear to the child of god
what is the difference if there is
between the trinity and the godhead
because that's often
the godhead is a greek word that refers
to the quality of god
it does not refer to the three members
of it refers to the quality the
qualities of divinity for instance when
you read romans 1 20
for the invisible things of him are seen
from the foundation or creation of the
world
even his eternal godhead and so the
qualities of god can be discerned by
honestly observing the things god has
made
so godhead does not refer distinguish to
three individual persons
it refers to the qualities that make a
divine being
a divine being so the godhead of god
would be the qualities of god
so in nature nature does not teach us
there are three members of the godhead
nature does not teach us that but nature
certainly teaches us
that there's order there's design
there's love
there's beauty in the godhead there is
life
nature teaches us those things so
godhead refers to that which makes the
divine being divide
but godhead does not mean trinity
strictly
even though it points the mind in that
direction the word trinity is not in the
bible
but it's still biblical the word sex is
not in the bible but who would deny it
so godhead refers the qualities divine
qualities
amen thank you so very much it refers to
three
intelligent living co-equal beings go
equal in the sense
each one is fully divine it's called
eternal also
core eternal means each one has always
been there
core eternal mean eat one didn't start
before the other
and these are concepts that caused the
mind to to crack they have
always been there all three they caught
eternal
each one is fully divine but they have
different
functions they have different functions
very much like let's say the husband and
the wife genesis chapter 2 verse 24
and i may be going off a little but i
think i ought to do that the bible says
therefore shall a man
leave his father and his mother this is
the creator speaking by the way not adam
and shall cleave unto his wife and there
shall be one flesh
so the same way a man and a woman can be
one flesh father son and holy spirit can
be one
yet three distinct beings as you have
two distinct beings in the marriage but
they are
one and when a child comes we have three
members
in the family one family but three
distinct beings
but each one 100 a family member
and so the human family helps us to
understand the oneness of godhead
because we were made in god's image
and god's image is not just the
character it is the way things
function and operate the man as the head
is a reflection of the image of god
all right amen amen